hey 42 here sometimes everything just
seems to go your way you head out on
your morning commute to find the road
inexplicably empty you buy a coffee and
the cashier accidentally gives you too
much change
you meet your tinder date and despite
your rock-bottom expectations she turns
out to not have a face like scrambled
eggs on days like this your kingdom
eiders jabbing everything in sight and
giggling madly as it turns into gold
you're a harry potter with a belly full
of Felix Felicis catching snitches and
hexing fools for mere mortals like you
and me days like these might be
memorable but most of the time they have
no real lasting impact to a professional
athlete however a day when everything
just goes right could be life-changing
this is probably the reason so many
sports stars have weird and wonderful
superstitions and pregame routines it
said that serena williams wears the
exact same pair of socks for every game
during a tennis tournament and michael
jordan always wore a pair of powder-blue
University of North Carolina shorts
under his Chicago Bulls kids rumor has
it this is actually the reason modern
basketball players wear such London
Bakke short today Michael Jordan set the
trend in order to cover up his lucky
charms in more ways than one
and it caught on but why water
superstars of this magnitude bother with
silly rituals the answer to that
question would probably make up a pretty
good doctoral thesis but I think part of
it is simple no matter how good you are
you're always striving after that
magical day when the whistle blows all
the stars are gun fires and for a few
brief minutes
you're perfect if that means wearing a
lucky pair of shorts or cultivating new
strains of bacteria in your socks then
so be it
during the Olympic Games in Mexico City
in 1968 a young athletes named Bob
Beamon
from New York had one of those rare
perfect
and in doing so did something that is
considered by many to be the single
greatest accomplishment in their history
of athletics an achievement so stunning
it spawned a brand new word Beeman asked
that sport historians used to this day
to describe sporting feats that are so
incredible as to be almost unbelievable
but we're getting a little ahead of
ourselves here
the Mexico Summer Olympics were the
first to be held in Latin America and
the first to be televised in color
around the world it's fair to say
expectations were high and the games did
not disappoint looking back the Mexico
games are probably best remembered for
the protests of African American
athletes Tommie Smith and John Carlos
the pair had won gold and bronze
respectively in the 200 meters and each
raised a black gloved fist during their
medal ceremony as the American national
anthem played to protest against racial
inequality in the u.s. at the time away
from the politics a young George Foreman
was busy battling his way to boxing gold
a year before turning professional dick
Fosbury worm gold in the high jump
whilst pioneering the flop technique
that people swore blind would never
catch on and badass John Steven a quarry
crossed the finish line over an hour
behind the winner in the marathon the
reason for his terrible time he
dislocated his knee whilst jockeying for
position lesson halfway through the 26
mile race yet
he still managed to finish the Mexico
Games also saw the first ever Olympic
doping disqualification after
regulations and testing were brought in
for the first time I'm guessing you're
thinking the culprit Swede hands gone
early Jim wall was found to have taken
steroids or was perhaps partial to a
side of EPO with his dinner not even
close
the pan athlete and certified lad was
actually disqualified for knocking back
a couple of cheeky pints before the
pistol shooting event because you know
guns and alcohol are a great combo but
in amongst all this chaos and
competition it was in the long jump
final one
sports greatest ever achievements would
take place to say Bob Beamon had had a
rough childhood it would be something of
an understatement born in 1946 in Queens
New York Beeman's mother died of
tuberculosis before his first birthday
and the man he fought to be his father
until the age of 17 turned out to have
actually been in prison at the time of
Beeman's conception Bob spent much of
his childhood bouncing around various
relatives houses poverty hot on his
heels perhaps unsurprisingly he had a
tough time of it in school earning
himself expulsion from kindergarten for
turning up to show-and-tell with a
switchblade and a 38 millimeter Smith &
Wesson not quite the half-chewed cuddly
toy and kick-ass marble collection that
I remember from my own childhood by his
teenage years Beeman had fallen in with
some bad dudes rising to the position of
war counselor for the local gang the
Frenchman in his own words he was out of
control as the old cliche goes it was
sports that saved him entering a nearby
competition on something of a whim
fifteen-year-old Beeman jumped seven
meters 34 centimeters in winning the
long jump event and got his name
published in the newspaper for his
troubles it was to be the catalyst for a
truly remarkable career by the time the
Mexico Olympics rolled round and 68
Beeman was 22 already the American long
jump and triple jump champion he had a
personal best in the long jump of 8
meters 33 centimeters the second longest
distance ever left unfortunately for him
the two men who'd gone further were also
competing in Mexico City joint world
record holders Ralph Boston he was
Beeman's teammate and the gold medalist
from the Rome Olympics in 1960 and
Soviet competitor Igor tur over Nacional
these two Spring Heeled Mavericks had
dominated long jump over the previous
decade breaking the world record eight
times between them and stretching the
limit of unaided human flight by 14
two meters in that time Boston and her
over nescient
had both been on the podium in Tokyo
four years before and the gold medalist
from that year a Welshman with the
wealthiest of names Lynne Davies or
Lynne the leap to his buddies was also
competing it was fair to say Beeman how
did work was hard for him but his
competitors were also more than a little
wary in return
Ralph Boston is said to have told Davies
not to try and get in Beeman's head in
the run-up to the event with a warning
that in hindsight who is oddly prophetic
don't get him riled up Lynne else he's
liable to jump out the pit
thanks to a stunning runner form leading
up to the Mexico Games which saw him win
22 of his previous 23 competitions
Beeman was actually seen by the
bookmakers as narrow favorite for the
event
despite the pedigree of his competitors
but bob was inexperienced at this level
and it nearly cost him as he fouled his
first two jumps in qualifying one more
mistake and he'd have been heading home
with nothing more to show for his
troubles than a pocket full of sand on
his third jump he measured his run up
from well behind the board nailed a
legal jump and qualified for the final
in second place behind Boston the night
before the final Beeman was a pack of
nerves perhaps taking inspiration from
fellow olympian hands Connolly Jim Wall
who we heard from earlier Bob knocked
back a couple of tequilas who studied
the nerves for most people working up a
stonking hangover before the biggest day
of your life would probably be a bad
idea for Bob Beamon
hit worked a treat next morning standing
at the end of the runway
bob was deep in the zone he paused for a
full
two seconds breathing deeply and shaking
out his letters shifting his stance he
took a few deep breaths rocked back and
forth on his heels then set off down the
track like a streak of lightning the guy
was fast he could run the hundred yard
dash the Aldi world is slightly shorter
version of 100 meters in 9.8 seconds Bob
hit the board with an audible crack and
flew into the air understandably we
think of long jumpers as jumping a long
way horizontally but that morning in
Mexico Beamen was high according to
Olympic legend than previous long jumped
world-record holder
Jesse Owens he was commentating for
radio at the time he might have been six
feet off the ground at the apex of his
job Bob seemed to hang in the air for a
long time before landing almost out of
the pit it quickly became clear this was
a big jump
mostly because the high-tech optical
measuring device introduced for the
Mexico Games didn't extend far enough to
actually measure the job the reason for
this was simple nobody thought it was
possible for a human being to jump that
far the final had to be suspended for a
full 20 minutes whilst officials
rummaged around in some nearby cupboards
in search of a tape measure
during the weights the other competitors
could be seen speculating as to just how
far Beeman had got back then most of
them were used to distances being
recorded in feet and inches the world
record at the time was 27 feet four and
three-quarter inches and there were
whispers that Beeman's jump was so huge
he might have become the first man in
history to break the 28 feet mark trusty
low-tech tape measure in hand the
officials got down and dirty in the Sun
pit to measure his job after a
nerve-racking wait the results were him
as it turned out Bob Beamon had indeed
become the first man in history to break
the 28-feet mark and that alone would
have been enough to see wild
celebrations erupted in the stadium but
something much more miraculous just
happened because Bob had also become the
first man in history to break the 29
feet mark he'd smashed a world record by
an almost inconceivable 55 centimeters
almost two feet in a single jump so you
put that into perspective since records
began in 1901 no long jumper had beaten
the previous record by more than 15
centimeters and the average increase
during that time was less than 6
centimeters or two compared Beeman's
records to another discipline the
fastest hundred meters in history is
nine point five eight seconds run by
Usain Bolt in 2008 Beamen improves the
long jump world record by more than 6%
in one go
which would be the equivalent of someone
lowering vaults 100 meters time to eight
point nine five seconds today it took
Bob a minute or two to realize what he'd
done his distance had flashed up on the
board at 8 meters 90
it wasn't until his old pal Ralph Boston
explained Bob had jumped over 29 feet
that it really hit home a Beeman was so
overwhelmed his legs collapsed
underneath him as he suffered a
cataleptic shock a complete loss of
muscle stem brought on by extreme
emotion it would be several minutes
before he would be able to walk again
defending champion Lynn Davies some
things up pretty nicely when he walked
over to beaming and disbelief moments
later and said simply you have destroyed
this event unsurprisingly nobody got
close to Beeman's jump that day in
Mexico City East German Klaus beer came
in second place his jump coming in a
gaping 71 centimeters shorter more than
50 years later
nobody has jumped further in the
Olympics than Bob Beamon in fact it's
the longest held Olympic
record by far Sergei listen Yelp's
hammer fro from the soul game came close
and that was set a full 20 years after
Beeman's incredible jump Beeman's shadow
has hung over the sport ever since even
/ Bob himself it will be 12 years before
anyone would even break the 28 feet mark
for a second time let alone 29 and
Beeman never landed another jump
remotely close to his own record not
only did he never managed a jump of 29
feet for the rest of his life he never
even managed 27 it was quite simply a
freak event a magical day when
everything went right for one man thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
then please consider supporting me on
patreon because it really helped me to
continue to make these videos the links
in the description also you can get your
hands on a first edition signed copy of
my new book stick a flag in it by
heading on over to unbound publishing
with the links in the description and
pre-ordering your copy today thank you